let's talk about uh let's talk about
this movie wander that you did
um you worked with uh aaron eckert in
this
uh in this in this movie and i'm told
that he went method he was doing some
very method like honestly sometimes we
were talking i couldn't tell if i was
really talking to him or he was in
character
um like you know he had to have like
dirt on him in some scenes and usually
like a makeup artist will put it on you
but he would just grab
dirt off the ground and just like smear
it all over himself and
be like really angry and one day i was
driving to work and i just
you know i was like oh there's this
homeless man sitting outside the set
like on this curb
and it was it was aaron maybe he's had
financial setbacks
have you ever thought about that
um let's show a clip from uh wander and
i believe
uh he is very paranoid you're meeting in
this senior meeting
with him in a diner yeah and um
he of course very paranoid and uh
you think that this is all about him
being off his meds not taking care of
himself
yes and we'll find out maybe that's the
case
but maybe it isn't maybe not yes let's
take a look at this clip
you haven't been going to your
appointments that's because sometimes i
can't tell who's the doc and who's not
that's a whack job you want to get
better you got to go to your
appointments
i i'm just looking out for you i just
grown-up show
how about you and nick
mr tall dark and fbi why can't you just
be happy for me
i'm looking out for you you're looking
out for me you don't think it's at all
coincidental
that he just happened to be transferred
into town and he'd go out with you yeah
you're going too far with this
conspiracy thing and you know what i
blame jimmy yeah well at least he
believes me well you met him in 5150
he's a crazy person
i mean he gets in your head he provokes
oh hey gee shell
don't hold back my only friend what
about me
can we get a check and we're back
love that that was fast at home they
just saw a clip
but we don't show the clip on zoom here
now wow
really phony thing where i say let's
take a look and then you and i are just
staring at each other and i say and
we're back
i know um you know
i apologize for that it's very
unprofessional but
i think it's fun i'm so happy to talk to
somebody who's not in my close family
group right now i mean it's it's it's
fun
yeah probably getting tired of the
boyfriend
that's what's happening a lot of
relationships are under strain right now
because of quarantine
you know what i've never dated anyone
norwegian i think i need to
think about that okay can i just say one
thing i hope it lasts forever with this
guy i really do
but if you date another norwegian for
any reason
uh or you know uh any guy who's
they should have a real exotic name okay
okay
okay you know what name would be
acceptable to you for example
that should be his name just call him
that
you know tonight when he's in the
kitchen making this fantastic meal that
i would never know how to cook
say great too much salt
okay that would be an awesome name it
would
um i also want to mention the stand is
coming out
very soon and that was shot before all
of this craziness
yeah i mean it's about a pandemic yeah
and it's about a virus
you know that kills all these people and
we shot it in october
a year ago about you know a little more
than a year ago so in a way
by making that movie maybe
you can you blame me for the pandemic is
that what you're saying
i do
you